I'm gonna get a shirt that says I was
there for the really kick-ass summer
movie season of 2014 I'm gonna get that
[ __ ] cuz it's real dawn of the Planet of
the Apes so dawn in the Planet of the
Apes is a sequel to Rise of the Planet
of the Apes I'm like four years fighting
the virus and other four fighting each
other and then a couple years apiece Oh
about ten years later and Donna the
Planet of the Apes Caesar has ultimately
his tribe it's really cool seeing the
apes interact and just exists because
it's an entire culture you look at it
you're like yep your primitive sure but
you're there your sentient you're
learning you have schools and [ __ ] you
have a code of conduct you have
consequences you have your leader Caesar
is awesome once more seriously sit like
all the apes are just talking and
chattering and they're all just kind of
upset about something Caesar just goes
like this and they're like shut up
Caesar has such command over the
Triborough you're like that dude is he's
Caesar and then humans run into Apes for
the first time in quite a while now
there's instant friction and right after
that I saw how the movie was gonna plaid
I was like oh it's gonna be like this no
surprise but I'm pretty sure it'll still
be cold there's like nope we'll take a
dip this way surprised and I was like
all right well now it's gonna play out
like this movie was like nope another
turn this way surprise you at the movie
did not play out how I thought it was
gonna play out and I love that [ __ ] I
felt like the movie was taking me to
school works like no no sit back let us
tell you the story and the hearings are
good in the movie the main dude who
plays the main human he's good I feel
like I want to say he's functional but
he actually was good in the movie the
thing is he was just eclipsed by Caesar
first of all Andy Serkis has Caesar he's
great as Caesar but I like about this
movie is the Apes clearly have different
personalities there are different actors
playing the different Apes in the movie
and you see it you're like yeah that one
is like you know this kind of person
that one's like this kind of person
scene stealer I'm going to talk about
this dude Koba in the movie holy [ __ ]
he's a dick for sure but he's passionate
about his perspective he was the one who
was messed with and experimented on he
has all the scars from Rise of the
Planet of the Apes so now when dawn of
the Planet of the Apes he's like no I
just don't trust humans he's angry he's
bitter this movie has social
implications I love that [ __ ] it made a
movie not so black-and-white the movie
is very great when the movie ended I
looked at the dude at the right I mean I
was like well that was a very volatile
movie and that's not a bad thing the
movies just it's very tense everything's
on the razor's edge you're on the edge
of your seat you're like man I just feel
like [ __ ]
it's gonna go down you so want peace to
happen in this movie but there are those
who just don't want things to happen and
the movie looks great - you thought Rise
of the Planet of the Apes looks good
holy there are a couple scenes I mean
it's a close-up of an Apes face and I
was like that's a real Apes face this
movie's the perfect place the perfect
kind of movie I want for a movie like
this it looks great it has great CGI
it's exciting it has good action when
the shit's going down it is going down
but it's also smart and has good
character development it has good
relationships within the movie the
movies very human even though the
majority of the cast in this movie are
Apes the movies runtime isn't absurdly
long anything like that I'm pretty sure
it's around 2 hours long but it's just
so full of content that it's not wasted
the movie is optimized it's as long as
it needs to be any shorter and you'd be
like ok it was good but it could have
been a little longer and longer and
you'd be like oh the movie was longer
than it needs to be it is literally the
perfect amount of time a lot of the
stuff worked for me in this movie I love
the humans I love the Apes I love the
situation I love the social implications
I love the tension I love the excitement
I'm telling you Donna the Planet of the
Apes is worth buying on blu-ray because
Donna the Planet of the Apes is awesome
Jack Uhler you thought I was gonna stop
at blu-ray but it did should Andy Serkis
get an Oscar for this movie I would say
sure if I gave a [ __ ] if I felt that it
mattered it doesn't matter I mean that
in the best possible way for Andy Serkis
I mean I imagine when you're an actor
getting an Oscar is a pretty cool thing
sure oh really me saying he should get
an Oscar as me saying he should get a
pat on the back and impress a bunch of
old people who were no doubt part of the
first wave of lifeboats on the actual
Titanic at this point my life I have
gone hell yeah Academy all right
whatever Andy Serkis is one of the best
actors in the business you know it I
know Andy Serkis you're great you were
great in this movie you will continue to
be great whether or not you impress a
bunch of old boring ass people it
doesn't matter what I want most is for
Andy Serkis to keep making movies that's
what I want Donna to the Planet of the
Apes have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more